[Musique]
e
oui
les mauriciens et ne viennent en masse
pour nous aider avec la confection des
boudins
et ces boudins lens ont pris part des
bateaux des bateaux volontaires les
bateliers de miles pour les plaisanciers
de gbagbo on met à disposition la bateau
volontairement pour aller placer boudin
emmerdes et grâce à ça les boudins
arrive à retenir l'huile déversée le wac
à chaud
avec un ami en lui nous sommes venus
aujourd'hui pour donner un coup de pouce
c'est parce que c'est la dégradation de
notre environnement
[Musique]
tout l'écologie marins sont affectés
pour l'une août qui a été déversée par
le pôle bateaux et nous sommes très très
très touché par ce problème mais en trop
c'est notre priorité reste
parlant ventoux protéger notre lagon de
mahébourg
[Musique]
maîtrise pour nous
notre travail le pca les bateliers ne
soigne pas trop travail oit ratifiées
libre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
le
[Musique]